- Decker.
Agent Jackson, you'll be working
with him on this mission.
- Agent Jackson, let's
get one thing straight,
I don't like orders and I
don't play by the rules.
I trust you heard of me?
- Actually, no, I haven't.
- Ohhh.
Hubba hubba.
♪ Well, I want you
but I don't need ya ♪
(poppy club music)
- That's right,
Sergeant Krandle,
United States Army recruiter.
How y'all doing?
This my associate
Sergeant Grampacks.
Yeah.
- Huh, huh, huh, huh.
Nice beat, gentlemen.
- We wanna talk to
you about your future
and where you fit in the
United States Army y'all.
- In case you haven't heard,
we're asking and you're telling.
- That's right, no
restrictions, man.
You gon' be surrounded
by dudes all day.
Y'all can exercise together.
You can shower together.
- Talking bout soap,
water, the works.
- Now, I know what
you're thinking,
the army's dangerous,
but the fact of the matter
is everything's dangerous.
- All depends on
what your definition
of the word danger is.
- Uh-oh, yeah.
- What!
- Oh, here we go.
- Oh, we gotta friend.
- Hey, Navy already got him.
(Key chuckling)
But you're better
off in the Army,
cause we gon' get you in the
best shape in your whole life.
- Whoo!
Talking about a six pack.
- Blip!
- Gon' give you an eight pack.
- Sklimp!
- Hey, we'll even
give you a jet pack!
(Key laughing)
- That's a joke, man, he
a joker, he a funny guy.
We ain't got jet packs.
- Whoa, whoaaaa!
- Oh, that's my cut.
- Go ahead, go ahead.
Hey, hey, hey.
You got to isolate,
then isolate
then is-o-late.
- Oh yeah!
Tell you something
right now, man.
Combat is just a buncha
men in a tight space
with flashing lights
and loud noises!
(Peele beatboxing)
- Just like this!
Yeah, you'll fit
right in at home!
- It's gon' be great,
man, y'all gonna love it.
Oh, here it is.
Can't stop it,
can't stop it, what.
- Go Krandle.
Sergeant Krandle.
Krandle, Krandle, Krandle and
hold it.
Hold it.
And hold it right there.
- Whoo!
I'm a robot!
(Key knocking on stall door)
Excuse me in there, young man.
Have you ever thought about
joining the United States Army?
Yes, oh, oh, excuse me.
I will talk to you
two later, pardon me.
(helicopter chopping)
(eerie dramatic music)
- Decker.
Agent Jackson,
you'll be working with
him on this mission.
- Agent Jackson, let's
get one thing straight,
I don't like orders and I
don't play by the rules.
I trust you heard of me?
- Actually, no I haven't.
- Ohhh.
Hubba hubba.
- We don't have much time.
The Arachnid agents have
taken over the consult.
- We need to get you in and
resolve this from the inside.
We've taken the latest sit-rep
of the hostiles' position
and we've reconstructed
a holographic blueprint
of the consulate.
- Save the mouth squirt for
the new recruits, General.
Not gonna be impressed by
any fancy, new technology!
(Decker grunting fearfully)
(Decker breathing hard)
- It's just a 3D representation.
Pretty standard these days.
- Right.
I know what it is.
- Agent Jackson,
you will enter
through this AC duct
on the south side
of the building.
- Yes, sir.
- Decker,
you will be dropped on top
and then you will gain access
through this elevator shaft.
We want you to go down
to the fourth floor.
Make ...
Decker!
You okay?
- Heard everything you said.
Elevator shaft.
It's bright.
- Yeah, it's bright.
The terrorists are located
on the third and fifth floor
of the building.
Each floor has six
groups of six men.
What we're gonna want you to do
is stop in the
middle of the fourth
and pry open the
elevator door and go ...
I just want you to move
through that elevator door
and then go ...
Pry open ...
Elevator door and go down
to the third floor ...
Okay, maybe this
isn't gonna work out.
- Why?
What's the matter, General?
Everybody's putting
their hand in the laser.
- It's not a laser.
It's a hologram.
- Tomato tomato.
Look, what's with all the
babysitting and handholding?
Papa's a big boy.
- Let's zoom into the interior.
- Yeah, let's zoom in.
(Decker yelling in shock)
Let's cut to the chase.
Why am I here?
- Your primary target is your
old rival from the Cold War,
Nikolai Andrekovich.
Now, Andrekovich
has been leading a -
- Here's here!
(Agent Jackson moaning in pain)
- What?
Jackson!
Dammit.
(dramatic music)
Good job, Decker.
Jackson was an undercover
agent for Arachnid.
How in the world did you know?
- Ain't my first rodeo.
(Decker screaming in pain)
Hot!
In my day, we made coffee hot.
- He's here, he's here.
- Come on, baby, get your sign.
Brandon, bring the camera.
Come on, let's go.
Hold it out, hold it
out right for Daddy,
so Daddy can see.
There you go.
(dog barking)
- Rocky!
My boy!
There's my boy!
- [Child] He brought
me a teddy bear.
- [Mom] He did bring
you a teddy bear.
- Oh my Gosh, look
at this good boy.
Hey, you want that?
You want that toy?
- [Child] Why isn't
he coming, Mommy?
- [Mom] He's
coming, he's coming.
- [Dad] Oh my Gosh, I
love you so much, Rock.
Hey, let's go, come on, boy.
Good dog, good dog, there we go.
Oh, I missed her so much!
That's my Rocky!
- Gentlemen, it has been
a pleasure and an honor
to meet you and your people.
The US government supports
you in every possible way.
(Ambassador slapping
bug on his head)
Ideologically, of course.
However, we cannot offer any
military aid at this time.
- With all due
respect, Ambassador,
we need more than that.
- We are dealing with
terrorism on a daily basis.
- Oh, that's unfortunate.
- Warlords overrun villages.
- Yes, that's regrettable.
- Rapes, tortures,
all manner of human atrocity.
- That's really sad,
but the US military is
simply spread too thin.
We can't afford another
intervention at this time.
- But what we could use
your help with, really,
is protecting our
vulnerable, plentiful,
and newly discovered
oil reserves.
- Oil?
Excuse me, one second.
(walkie talkie beeping)
Operation Golden Eagle is a go.
(helicopters chopping)
(people gasping)
(planes and helicopters roaring)
Welcome to democracy.
(war drums beating)
- We also have natural gases!
- Oh, yes a lot!
Lots of it!
- Commander (indistinct)
Our forces have been devastated.
The enemy is at the
edge of the village.
There are not many of us left.
Should we surrender?
- You may surrender, Django,
but I'm afraid that is a
luxury I cannot afford.
You have no idea what
they do to warlords.
If they capture me,
they will torture me for weeks.
That is no way to go.
I want you,
my most trusted soldier
over the age of eight,
to take my life.
That is
my final order.
(General screaming)
(Django stabbing Key)
Stop, stop!
What the hell are you doing?
(General screaming)
- I was trying to kill you, sir.
- Not with this!
There's a gun in the drawer!
(General groaning in pain)
- Ohhhh.
So sorry, okay.
- Amazing.
You missed every
vital organ, Django.
- Found it!
- Alright, now kill me,
Django, hurry, please!
(gun firing)
(General screaming)
Not in the knee!
- I thought you might
want an open casket.
- You are an idiot!
(General groaning in pain)
- Don't say that,
I did try my best.
- Shoot me in the
head, you imbecile.
- Goodbye, Commander.
You sorry-ass piece of sh -
(gun clicking)
- Did you just insult me
as you were about to fire?
- Oh, well,
you had insulted me earlier.
I thought you would be dead.
Ooh, so sorry.
- Ow!
Ow!
Ow! Ow!
Stop, stop it!
What the hell are you doing?
- Gun is empty.
Would you like I stab you again?
- No, no, no, please!
Django, there are bullets.
They are over there!
- Okay.
- Django, please
hurry, I am in agony!
(pot hitting General)
(General screaming)
What the blazes, man?
- I thought I could
kill you very quick
by hitting you with
that big cooking pot.
- Oh my God, would you please,
I mean, please get it over with?
- I did not find the bullets.
- What?
- But better,
boiling hot water.
- What are you
going to do with -
(General screaming)
I surrender!
I am the General (indistinct)
- Commander, don't go!
They'll torture you!
(dramatic, suspenseful music)
(birds chirping)
- I was wondering when I
would come in here to find you
sitting in that chair.
- Wasn't easy tracking
you down, Decker.
- Wasn't supposed to be.
- I know you've retired, but -
- That's all behind
me now, General.
I'm not the man you knew
during the Cold War.
- I understand.
We're now facing a threat
unlike any we've
ever faced before.
A man with your expertise ...
- I made a vow
never to kill
another human being.
Sorry, General.
Gonna have to find someone else.
- Oh.
No.
We weren't thinking you'd do it.
We were
(General clearing his throat)
just hoping you could
recommend someone for the job.
- I guess I could come
out of retirement.
- No.
No need.
Just a recommendation will do.
- Alright.
(Decker stabbing table)
I'll do it.
- You know, you're just
not what we're looking for.
- You sly son of a bitch.
You always knew how
to push my buttons.
I'm in.
- Not
you,
Decker.
- Sharp as I ever was,
even faster too.
Grab my hand.
Nope.
Wait til I count to three first.
One,
two,
three.
Okay.
I want you to try and
slap me in the face.
(General slapping Decker)
Ohhh, wasn't ready for that.
Try again.
(General slapping Decker)
Okay, you know what?
- What?
- Didn't have my adrenaline up
cause this is not an actual
high stakes situation.
Alright.
Draw your weapon.
And disarmed.
(gun clicking)
You're getting pretty quick.
And disarmed, okay.
I don't need to
take your weapon.
You know what?
Shoot me.
- I am not going to shoot you.
- Wing me in the shoulder.
- This is ridiculous.
- Try, General.
See what happens.
(gun firing)
Deflected.
Owwww!
- Okay, I made a
mistake coming here.
- Wing me in the other shoulder.
- I'd rather not.
- [Decker] I insist.
(gun firing)
(Decker screaming)
That was because my other
arm was already injured.
- Okay, I'm leaving.
- Alright.
All or nothing.
Gut shot.
- No!
- Gut shot, come on!
If you can shoot me in
the gut, I'll concede.
- Decker, you have
two wounded arms.
- Gut shot! Go!
(gun firing)
Caught it.
(Decker groaning weakly)
- You caught the bullet?
So, you're telling
me that the bullet
is in between your hands
right now?
- That's what I'm telling you.
Is that all you got?
Come on.
Head shot.
(Decker groaning weakly)
Head shot, let's go.
I'm ready.
Wait one second, though.
(gun firing)